what was uh
dizzy you toured with tech9 a couple
years ago i did
i did and uh that's its own kind of
world right music thing and then also
just touring there
like with them like the rules are crazy
like
the bus rules and they'd be and
[ __ ] like travis don't play
oh yeah um like i know a lot of people
who
have either just quit those tours or
gotten kicked off the tours and
yeah um how how was that experience
touring with tech9 and and
just getting getting into that world and
then also kind of
just dealing with all the strange music
[ __ ] man it was like
inspiring but it was also extremely
tough you know
you can't smoke on the bus right yeah
you can't smoke the smoking on the bus
isn't what bothered me
uh i think it's the going to venues that
i went to
by myself that
you know they have they have rooms for
me to smoke in
you know they got ducked off areas for
me to be you know they know they like
dizzy coming we got to make sure that we
got a fan
upstairs and we open the windows and let
them be
you know upstairs and away from
everybody and like you know some of
those places we were coming to that had
like those setups for me
uh strange music was shutting me down
and that [ __ ] was eating at my spirit a
little bit because you know i
i thrive off not having no weed problems
i know i talk a lot about weed and [ __ ]
but
it's not cool to get in trouble for the
[ __ ] you got to be smart you got to move
smart and i
i you know i dropped the album my first
album on 420 in 2012
and i ain't never had a problem never
had a run-in with the police
about weed not once you know in my whole
career
i'm not bragging or like showing off i'm
just just trying to make it
apparent like on how serious it is you
know and
especially in some of those random
markets you'll be in and what i install
on my team
you know because it's not just me like i
ain't never had nobody on the road with
me
get into no weed trouble you know like
personally somebody that i brought
no [ __ ] we all on the same page you
know what i'm saying for years so being
on
the road with strange music and
having doing this for so long and always
finding a way to stay out of the way i
felt like they kind of
you know they don't want you smoking in
the venue they don't want you smoking
backstage they don't want you smoking on
the bus they don't want you smoking in
the hotel so it's like
where do you want me smoke you want me
to go outside in front of you then you
might get in trouble the fans in front
of people
in front of businesses it felt more like
i was being put
in danger kind of like instead of being
ducked off
normally you know and i had i called
travis to trip with him about this
[ __ ] cause i'm like man travis i'm
feeling like you don't you you [ __ ]
putting us in like dangerous situations
he just like you know the rules
it's just like yo was that the toughest
tour to be on very
very much so um very much so
uh i was inspired by
tech you know and
just what he was able to build you know
i'm just so inspired by
you know him and what he was able to do
and how he's able to get up there and
the show he's able to put on and the
tournament
every single city yeah yeah he's really
inspiring and he don't complain he
loves what he do like it's it's not like
you know he's not depressed he's not
you know complaining he's not
drunk wilding out he's just tech you
know he's working out he's [ __ ]
but you know [ __ ] i feel the same way i
feel like i'm i'm an easy person to work
with you know i just need to be able to
you know
do my little smoke thing when i need to
do my little smoke day
and you know maybe not blow it down on
the bus where it might bring
some extra attention to other people but
you know when you're at these shows you
definitely want to be comfortable
especially before you get on stage
so it was inspiring but it was also
extremely tough for me
i can imagine um hey bro that honestly
that's the thing that's like
we live in we live in l.a and vegas
people
where it's legal and you know what i'm
saying and like
when we traveling and [ __ ] like that you
get some places and
and you see how that actual state really
frowns on this [ __ ] and then imagine not
being able to smoke in the venue where
you tucked away like
anything could happen to you out there
in the streets if
if you're in one of those states and
it's a shame because six hours away you
you're good six hours away you're good
and then six hours from here you
you like oh you know so much is on the
line and so i'm like they don't
even allow smoking outside in some of
the places where they kind of wanted us
to just kind of smoke outside
yeah you know it's not my thing you know
i i try to do well we're kind of
staying ducked off and out the way you
know what i'm saying i don't need to be
blowing it down all in everybody facing
things like that you know so
but you know at the end of the day uh
strange music
runs their [ __ ] the way they want to run
their [ __ ] and it works
and they've been successful and they run
it that way so they can keep
law and order and what they got going
and you got to respect that if you want
to be a part of that i went to be a part
of that [ __ ]
it was david i mean you signed up for it
you know i signed up for now
don't get me wrong i was told that i
could do my smoke thing now
now i i i agreed to not smoke on the bus
you know i don't know if i would i don't
know if i would have signed up to not
for it to be for me to be me and my team
to be put in those kind of situations
because you know [ __ ] it was raining
and snowing
what do you want me to type of [ __ ] and
then like yo i'ma get fined if i smoke
in the spot that they
that the venue says edibles i didn't i
didn't because
you might not be able to perform right
right so edibles is a
like a dangerous i like edibles when i'm
getting ready to go to sleep
you know so when i'm operating during
the day you know i just need to puff it
down a little bit i was just kind of
like
stressed out more than i'm normally
stressed out on the road you know i'm
saying so
other than that it was all love